wegen diesen komplett in feld zog man
dass du bist so lange so unkoordiniert
wie so ein automatischer staubsauger für
dich du bist lahm und unkoordiniert wie
ein automatischer staubsauger das ist
ein problem mit automatischen
staubsauger beide serien damit herzlich
kommen zu einem neuen leute das ist eine
fortsetzung von dem video was vor zwei
tagen kamen in dem video von vor zwei
tagen haben uns eine hilfen vergangene
schaut und haben anhand dieser hilfe
folge dass sehr sehr wichtige und von
gesellschaftlich aller höchster relevanz
sein thema mobbing auf baustellen
untersucht wir haben einen jungen mann
gesehen der einfach von seinen kollegen
ein reguliert wurde
dann ist dieser junge mann auf
wundersame weise aus dem bereits hart
gewordenen beton wieder rausgekommen
wohlgemerkt mit sauberen schuhen und
saubere hose voll das allerletzte szene
im letzten jahr wir gesehen wie dieser
junge mann an der straße läuft dann
kommen seine kollegen und stellten ihm
eine papiertüte über dem kopf
und was ihr dem moment vor hatten und ob
der junge mann vielleicht noch mal ein
betoniert wird das sehen wir jetzt mal
der mal so ein gesicht auf diese
papiertüte drauf gemalt denken geben sie
auch wirklich mühe also wir wissen heute
es ist ein ernstes problem also generell
mobbing also marie topleute mobbing ist
kein spaß um das thema ich hatte meine
eigene erfahrung mitgebracht damals
keine witze drüber
worüber wir allerdings wird zu machen
könnt ist das ist gesellschaftlich sehr
relevante problem mobbing auf baustellen
oder dem kontext ist wirklich mal seinen
kollegen schauer geben
was machen die fehler auf malta die
machen sich die mühe bitte nicht hinein
jetzt haben sie eben hier sofort
papiertüte mit einem wirklich schönen
gesicht drauf immer gestimmt also klar
sind [ __ ] aber es sind worin sich
die sich mühe gegeben habe
[Musik]
ganz klar natürlich er hat hier in der
situation der ob keine chance sich zu
wehren wie sehen
träger dieses seil ist hat einfach
überhaupt nicht gespannt und der typ
oben hält ihn mit seinen fingerspitzen
so fest also ganz ehrlich wenn er sich
minimal anstrengen würde könnte einfach
wegrennen
aber leute wie dürfe nicht vergessen
dass rtl2 hier laufen die dinge ein
bisschen anders
[Musik]
das auch wieder typisches phänomen von
rtl2 folgen scheinbar haben die keine
lust sich die drehgenehmigung für viele
verschiedene orte heranzuholen deswegen
passieren immer alle dinge an einem ort
und zufälligerweise laufen gerade die
richtigen leute vorbei gab das hier ist
jetzt seine mutter da frage ich mich
persönlich was macht seine mutter im
industriegebiet ich bin total sauer
zuerst machen mich meine kollegen auf
der baustelle total fertig und jetzt
folgen dem ich noch nach feierabend
was ist dass die zuwider läuft sein
vater auch noch zu berichtigen
industriegebiet das macht doch kein
mensch im industriegebiet spaziergängen
der zufälligerweise auch noch genau zu
dem gleichen zeitpunkt wo der sohn an
den pfosten gebunden wird meine pizza
die arbeitskollegen
aber ganz ehrlich leute mal rita der
stelle dieser marke ist richtiger
richtiger rabenvater als sein eigener
soll wird anpacken glatten 2 gebunden
von seinen kollegen also denn der sohn
arbeitet ihren gleichen zunimmt wie sein
vater markus und markus nimmt dann an
der stelle natürlich erstmal seine
arbeitskollegen stadt seinen eigenen
sohn in schutz
dazu kann man im zweifelsfall noch eins
sagen menschen nicht gesund ziemlich
abstoßend
ich schwitze ich rede mit seinen
kollegen wenn du meinst die waren das
mit denen darüber spricht dafür dass
außer dass er mit ihnen darüber spricht
er jungs bibel sky wir meinen sohn
fertig gemacht haben der hat jetzt
psychische schäden seien selbst wird
das massiv beschädigt er wird sein
ganzes leben lang und vertrauensproblem
durch die welt gehen einfach eine geile
aktion
[Musik]
der gab bitte mich nicht so ein scheiß
alter dürfen jetzt das toilettenhäuschen
umwelt er drin sitzt
[Musik]
okay was hat das jetzt gebracht haben
die baustelle weiter setzt den toiletten
hauswirth leyen
das ist nicht sehr effektiv dazu kommt
auch dass die tür aber die ganz offen
war
wenn ich so kollegen hätte würde ich
nicht mit offener tür ist das riskant
hier neue mutprobe neue aufgabe
du steigst du jetzt in den buggy schnaps
den schlüssel holst vor uns vom metzger
20 brötchen ganz kurz was haben wir da
hinten auf diesen baucontainer gemalt
ich weiß nicht geht jetzt meine geht
meine fantasie mit mir durch also was
was seht ihr bei dieser zeichnung hier
auf diesem baucontainer und zwar zügig
und daraus ist gleich vorbei ich aber
noch nicht mal einen führerschein ist
doch scheißegal
das ist ja das ist natürlich eine gute
logik auf jeden fall
scheinbar ist alles legal was in
baustellenfahrzeugen gemacht wird fahren
ohne führerschein in der regel strafbar
in deutschland fährt man allerdings in
baustellen falls sie ohne führerschein
ganz ehrlich wissen wir alle kommt man
natürlich straffrei davon ebenso verhält
sich mit mord oder mit gefährlicher
körperverletzung zu lange das quasi in
einem baustellenfahrzeug passiert dann
sind der polizei oft die hände gebunden
war soll die machen nichts auf die reihe
das geht doch gar nicht soll ich das mal
sagen soll ich mein vater das sagen der
ja was wir hören sollen aber jetzt
wieder gesund aggression was hat er
verpackt alter zu beraten was die gal
hat sich einfach einbauen lassen von
euch okay er hat ja bewiesen hat seine
fucking beine einmauern lassen in zement
der ja das ist ein richtiger hole bürger
dafür gegenseitig sagst du kriegst die
ganze zeit am laufenden band kriegst nie
was hin gibt's doch gar eine dünne folie
sagen dass wir keine bagger fahren kann
das war natürlich der us case leute ganz
ehrlich also an alle mieter ist da
draußen
übrigens main kanal glaube ich 75
prozent weibliche zuschauern hat also an
75 prozent von den leuten die das hier
gerade sehen würdet ihr mit einem typen
rumhängen der nicht bagger fahren kann
schreibt mal wird in die kommentare wie
wichtig baggerfahren für euch bei jungs
ist das macht das schon
[Musik]
egal wie schlecht gemacht ist diese
szene bitte
[Musik]
mega erfährt einfach so den gabelstapler
ist überhaupt kein aufprall und
irgendwas gezeigt und auf einmal liegen
dass scherben die scherben liegen auch
wohlgemerkt außen erst mit den zinken
von dem radlader vorne in die
fensterscheibe reingefahren also der
regel sollten die scherben nach innen
gedrückt werden auf rtl 2 ist es ganz
natürlich bisschen anders funktioniert
die physik einfach in umgekehrter
reihenfolge
[Musik]
das ist das auto von presse peter ganz
locker man nicht umsonst und war mal
peter crouch aus der karre autor richtig
schlecht gemacht geht mich das auto
immer das auto hat einfach um die
fensterscheiben warum einen lackschaden
habt ihr mal die schiffe von diesem
radlader gesehen da dieses fucking drei
meter einem 90 breit ich glaube was rtl
2 einfach gemacht hat wir einfach
irgendein andere glasscheibe zerschlagen
paar mal wird die scheibe von diesem
auto von links einfach runter gefahren
und haben einfach die scherben von dem
glas stück was sie vorher zu schlagen
haben einfach vors fenster gekippt
derweil das nenne ich mal
low-budget-produktion was machst du denn
hier kann man so sagen ja das hat mich
mein tag heute
also leute wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin ich
muss sagen ich hab so langsam hat mich
bisschen mitgefühl mit dem also am
anfang war das doch alles so mega absurd
so füße eingemauert und der ganze unsinn
und die ganzen unstimmigkeiten dieser
folge aber da diese nächtlichen scheiß
zu dem ich würde an der stelle einfach
mal zur lösung des problems vorschlagen
dass er mit dem radlader über zwei bis
drei der kollegen drüber fährt
[Applaus]
du bist halt eben anders als die uns ja
auf der baustelle und das ist auch okay
so und das ist auch so bleiben ich würde
schon sagen also anders als diese
schimpansen wie auf dieser baustelle
rumpel zu sein ist im zweifelsfall
wahrscheinlich sogar eine gute sache was
zu unternehmen gerettet alter in dem
moment ist es dann auch scheiße also
keine ahnung fucking baustellenfahrzeug
gefahren führerscheine ein auto
beschädigt füße einbetoniert worden auch
die toilette belästigt worden man könnte
heute wegen ihm oder ich finde denn er
hat sich das verdient mal bauernstaat
machen ja ich jetzt auch wieder
[Musik]
also wie gesagt dass da draußen ich bin
ich wirklich gespannt auf eure meinung
als ich meine danny kann offensichtlich
kein bagger fahren sie findet ihn
trotzdem interessant ich persönlich
freue mich da wie geht das
ich wollte eigentlich etwas trinken
gehen kannst du musst erst mal hier eine
schöne nachtschicht schieben der ja
richtig mies von den altar ist sonst ich
vertrete ich finde man kann sich diese
mittel hier also der lage auch nicht
vorhalten dass sie keine ahnung über die
interesse an einem jungen hat der heydt
mehr als eine gehirnzellen kopf hat kann
man ja eigentlich nicht übel nehmen hier
entsprechen sollte sich die einzeller
fraktion amtliche hier einfach mal
zurückhalten könnte einfach mal bringen
diese mehr komplett in verzug man dass
du bist so lahm
so unkoordiniert wie so ein
automatischer staubsauger ja was ist
aber der würde scheiße du bist lahm und
unkoordiniert wie ein automatischer
staubsauger das ist ein problem mit
automatischen staubsauger die dinger
sind geil geil ich habe einen mein
bruder hat ein die machen
ich schlafe ich ein naja allein die
vorstellung dass so etwas nicht passiert
dass du wirklich weh ich habe ich keinen
bock mehr ich würde am liebsten mag ich
glaube gesagt ehrwürdigen kaputt
schlagen
naja aber würde ich sagen die sache ist
so weit erklärt der nicht schlägt jetzt
kurz am mai kaputt der doppelt so gross
und doppelt so schwer wie er ist ihr
jack geht es um eine für euch
vorgeschlagene voll gehabt und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder biss dann